hey everyone it's sarah register
nursern.com and in this video i'm going
to demonstrate how to perform the
capillary refill test the capillary
refill test also known as capillary
refill time or nail blanch test is a
simple technique nurses can use to check
peripheral perfusion or for dehydration
so how do you perform the capillary
refill test it's performed by pressing
on the nail plate or the pad of a digit
for around 5 to 10 seconds causing the
nail bed or the pad of the digit to
lighten in color as the blood is
expelled then the nurse releases the
digit and observes the number of seconds
it takes for the tissue to regain its
natural color as blood flow returns and
it's important to know that sometimes
the capillary refill test is actually
performed on the sternum or the forehead
in some patient populations such as
newborns now what is considered a normal
versus abnormal capillary refill time
well typically if the blood returns to
the tissue within two seconds that's
considered normal so if it takes longer
than two seconds that's abnormal and
should be reported immediately however
some studies suggest that a normal
capillary refill time could be up to
three seconds in certain populations
therefore always refer to your
facilities guidelines for this time
range now what could cause an abnormal
capillary refill test in a patient well
when a patient's experiencing poor
peripheral perfusion where there's
limited blood flow going to those
extremities or even dehydration and some
common examples that could cause poor
peripheral perfusion include decreased
cardiac output and this may be due to
shock heart failure anemia or other
similar conditions bone fractures where
compartment syndrome is presenting and
this is where there is a restriction of
blood flow in the affected limb cast
care and placement if a cast is placed
on a broken limb capillary refill is
often assessed to ensure that proper
blood flow is reaching the extremity and
that the cast is not too tight
peripheral vascular disease and this is
the narrowing of vessels that can reduce
tissue perfusion raynaud's disease this
can cause vessels to spasm and narrow in
extremities that are exposed to cold
which reduces blood flow and then
finally hypothermia in addition some
factors can affect the reliability of
the capillary refill test and lead to
longer capillary refill times such as
cold temperatures edema swelling in
those extremities old age and smoking
now let me demonstrate how to perform
the capillary refill test on a
fingernail first you want to perform
hand hygiene then you want to greet the
patient explain the procedure and obtain
consent then choose a digit without nail
polish or anything that could restrict
blood flow to the area such as jewelry
or a watch if those items are present
you can either remove them or use an
alternate site then position the
patient's hand at or above heart level
and observe the patient's natural skin
color of the nail bed for reference
press on the nail plate or the pad of
the finger firmly for 5 to 10 seconds to
expel blood from the tissue then release
the fingernail and observe the number of
seconds it takes for the tissue to
return to its normal color which
indicates perfusion of the tissue for
accurate results use a watch to count
the seconds you'd follow the same
procedure if you were checking the
capillary refill on the pad of a digit
and here's an example of that if the
skin's natural color returns within two
to three seconds the capillary refill
test is considered normal if the
capillary refill time is longer than two
to three seconds it could suggest poor
tissue perfusion or dehydration and
these findings should be reported
immediately compare the results to a
digit from another limb if necessary and
again always refer to your facilities
protocols to determine the appropriate
guidelines for normal versus abnormal
refill time then perform hand hygiene
and document the capillary refill time
in seconds including the location for
example the fingernail of the index
finger on the right hand and other
necessary information per your
facilities protocol okay so that wraps
up this video on how to assess capillary
refill time and if you'd like to watch
more nursing skill videos you can access
the link in the youtube description
below